bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video su penombra io sono fa vj
eravamo rimasti l'ultima volta che
eravamo in nell'ufficio e niente devo
uscire di qua voglio soltanto
ringraziare il fatto che vi piace questa
serie perché non avete che se in tanti
si quindi era anche abbastanza ovvio è
comunque vi ringrazio perché mi avete
fatto capire che cosa servono sti affari
qui che non ho mai capito e premete
servono per salvare la partita già io
praticamente ho finito amnesia tutto
perché anche l'amnesia c'erano sti cosi
la storia principale
c'erano sì così ma io non capivo neanche
cosa servissero e l'ho finito senza
saperlo cioè io sono andato avanti a
finire videogames senza sapere che
quelli erano i punti di salvataggio
quindi vi ringrazio mi avete anche detto
che non si vede una ceppa quando cammino
al buio ma non è colpa della luminosità
del video semplicemente il gioco che è
cioè anch'io vedo non vedo niente quando
sono senza la traccia solo che sono
malato mentale gioco anche senza la
torcia quindi 9 lo faccio ogni tanto per
risparmiare le batterie della torcia
eccetera comunque se non vedete cerco di
illuminare di più eravamo rimasti che
c'era un cane male maledetto qui da
qualche parte e niente per la mente devo
devo andare avanti e lo sento da senso
c'era un cane che più che cane sembrava
un non morto però va beh noi proseguiamo
allora raga io non so più che fare qui
perché c'è una porta chiusa che era
quella di prima poi c'è gli oggetti non
c'è nulla quindi non so proprio che fare
sta roba
ok questo non l'avevo visto una specie
di botta ma non capisco dove possa
trovarsi una botola una botola
cerchiamo fiutiamo le botole ok non vedo
bordo le non a casa vita sfocerà che non
c'è una specie di corrente d'aria che
proviene dalla base c'è una specie di
corrente d'aria che proviene dalla base
lived ragazzi trovata incredibile non
pensavo io pensavo che cioè io penso lo
dovessi trovare una specie di esplosivo
per far esplodere la porta
invece no botola non si apre però sono
impedito anche nell'aprile the bottle è
ok perfetto sono sotto laga non è che mi
link sono tanto in questo momento mi
trovo precisamente sotto il pavimento di
quel tipo al tipo cui ho dato le scarpe
sparato qua c'è qualcosa che spunta
aspettate
c'è del sangue ok non ci vado non ci
tengo ragnatela perfetto se ci sono dei
ragni no no no ragni no
accidenti non ragni quello non mi piace
irani neanche a me sonora cnos o piccoli
odio
quindi niente ragni ragazzi vi prego
cos'è questo una scala che cosa ci fa
una scala qui sotto
perché ci deve essere una scala qui
sotto ragazzi bova beh io prosegue la
uso come autodifesa contro i ragni io
ragni ragazzi li detesto cos'è un cane
c'è un cane morto che visse per fatto
nemmeno unificato altrimenti chissà che
forza e c'è un ragno grosso come il tuo
braccio e tutti preoccupi della puzza
del cane
sì va bene non c'ho voglia di leggere
tutta sta roba raga sono vi annoiate
sono normalmente lo leggerei ho trovato
un razzetto potrà mai utile come ford
come fonte di luce va bene
speriamo non mi spunti il ragno ok al
quale potrebbe scegliere il corpo in un
istante lo so l'ho visto tu hai visto
una persona che si scioglieva poi grande
ok cosa questo un altra roba che non ci
voglia di leggere
c'è qualcosa lì sì se non fosse per la
loro dimensioni dire che sono gusci
d'uovo è ma visto che c'è un ragno che è
grosso come la tua testa penso che sia
uscito da lì poi non so come faccia
essere così grosso ma quelli sono
dettagli sta crollando tutto deve uscire
il prima possibile
ok ok ok sono uscito effetto ecco quello
che è rimasto il magazzino le piano
interrato della serratura sembra messa
piuttosto male
ok ok abbiamo io c'ho il martello di
thor che ricordate apre qualsiasi
breccia e tranne questa forum
ok perfetto ok a un'altra cosa che mi
avete consigliato posso mettere gli
oggetti sul 1 sul 2 così posso tirarli
fuori velocemente dal martello lo metto
sul 3
basta per adesso non c'è nient'altro la
carne ma vabbè cos'è sta roba gas per
ricaricare gli accendini prendilo che ti
serve togli il martello ok
bene perfetto altra roba qui che mi
serve niente questo niente questo
batterie
ok cos'è sta roba è una valvola giro in
giro giro cosa serve cosa è servito a
tutto ok perfetto allora adesso non mi
sciolgo più ragazzi
il ragno spero sia morto perché non
voglio professor me lo trovo davanti ad
esso pianto un urlo che che è meglio che
non lo metta nel video
no ragazzi veramente li detesto cioè
fanno veramente schifo ok io che me ne
vado me ne vado me ne vado
ne vado lo sento sempre più vicino ma
non so dopo piano che sono stai calmo
oddio è successo qualcosa al tipo della
stanza di fronte
ok andiamo andiamo andiamo andiamo è
successo qualcosa ragazzi devo andare a
controllare assolutamente è tutto a
posto
c'è paura
ok
credo che qualcuno sia stato trascinato
ma va non l'ho mai visto così tanto
sangue possibilità che ci sia ancora
qualcuno e mezzo le scarpe vuol dire non
te le sei messe perché non ti sei messo
le scarpe
cos'è sta roba da van terna vabbè chiave
giorno 200 una donna va bene ragazzi è
stato trascinato via al tipo mi dispiace
ok
cos'è sta roba una lingua la lingua
oddio che schifo ma per favore ma dai
che schifo non mi aprire il cassetto non
ti alzare che michia per ogni più grosse
che abbiamo visto con le budella
squartate meno male speriamo che senza
modella non si alzi una lingua la lingua
mi serve meno a posto perché oddio e
pervertita sa lingua
niente che schifo guardate come è
diventato un porno ragazzi ok raga io la
lingua conquisteremo il mondo lecca la
porta e aprirà ok perfetto gli piace
alla porta lo so
bene c'è un buco questo buco è troppo
stretto per un uomo non se vuoi provare
entrarci
non che intenda passaggio che sia chiaro
chi o cosa l'avrà scavato non lo so non
mi interessa usciamo di qui
cos'è carne essiccata noi la mia lingua
oddio la lingua è caduta di sotto lingua
scusami non volevo ok lo so la torcia
perché mi sembra più figo va bene
ragazzi o la chiave per qualcosa non so
cosa ha probabilmente per la porta e
volevo far saltare in aria
va bene è stata è stato tremendo fino
allora perché non è successo niente però
diciamo che la paura mi mi sta salendo
cioè sai che se pure su tasse come
faccio all'improvviso morirei ok prova
da questa porta con la chiave se riesco
ok
guido farmi mettere qualcosa davanti che
quel cane ancora gira non vorrei mai
ok elemento 2 ho sentite ok ne mette due
per sicurezza ma che prova a sfondarla
adesso allora meglio bloccare la porta
se quella specie di cane ancora non
voglio che mi si avvicini già bloccata
io sono avanti ragazzi non sfonderà mai
la porta lì ci deve essere un cane
radioattivo
devo riuscire a trovare
non so cosa perché non sanno che cosa
sto cercando adesso tnt mica esplosivo
potente mi serve ok io me lo porto
dietro questo si sa mai
ok lo ammetto hunter davanti alla porta
già che non riesce a spuntarla così ma
con questo se tenta di sfondare abdul
salta in aria
ok ragazzi non so che cosa mi serve sta
roba ma me lo sto portando dietro come
un idiota
ok a cazzo l'ha sfondata
no non ci credo non ci credo no ma
veramente salve ma non c'è
non c'e nessuno può invece sì addio
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no stai calmo no no no no no no no no
scherzavo
scherzavo scherzavo aiuto carne
essiccata carne carne carne essiccata e
darne ciccata prendi la carne la carne
ragazzi la carne c'era calmi a terra dio
ok ok ok ok ok ok martello martin
e quando è ancora vivo ed io gli ho dato
una martellata in faccia ancora vivo
vieni vieni che belle scappi adesso che
sono in vantaggio vieni qua una donna
che dai alzati dai alzati falsa in
teoria non c'è violenza contro gli
animali questo videogame ma questo non è
un animale è tutto qualche vulcano è
questo
ok niente niente niente
alzati adesso ancora vivo cioè michiara
cosa impressionante saperne c'è una
resistenza che scappa scappa scappa
scappa pure ok
ma ancora vivo 6 1 titolo cartello
vieni qua dove scacchi vieni qui
maya inizia a far rimanere anche in
serie c ok piano ma di loro dice meglio
che rimango qua solo lui che non si
rischia
ancora vivo aperte patti li devo dare
ragazzi e poi scappa poi torna c'è una
piccola cosa sta facendo
vieni qua vieni per combattere davvero
da vero pane uomo contro cara vieni qua
dalle scarpe
qui c'è una roccia non ho paura di
usarla non mi hai visto
cioè io sono passato per tu non mi hai
visto ma se è morto è morto veramente ho
paura riavvicinarmi tipo i film horror
ragazzi
non si sa mai si è morto
ok ragazzi è finita è finita
ce l'abbiamo fatta flachi era fa vj
batte i cani la vj versus dog workshop
va bene è stata un'impresa ragazzi ma
son riuscito a battere il cane cos'è
questo ho bisogno di un valore apertura
collocata solamente ed è più nuovo
rispetto a resto della miniera a devo
mettere non soffrano maria caso ma 37
questa roba boh a carne essiccata che
cosa verso a doremi e laboratorio
nessuno li darebbero soldi ma è un
ottima zona di caccia 1 qui non può far
altro che provocare ci sono dei numeri
scritti maiuscoli 21 48 21 48 48
ricordiamoci 2 1482 cos'erano 214 del 14
infatti non funziona mi sono già
dimenticato il codice ragazzi nota della
marcia ragni e vabbè mi laboratori
preferito si 21 48 e l'ho messo oggi
comunque la mente di red pensiero esatto
contrario
84 12 sarà anche a questo punto 4 1 2
pacchi s
entriamo io già nei puzzle raga vado in
difficoltà però eccellente un piccolo
passo verso la creazione degli esplosivi
senza perdere arti cosa ho preso filo di
cotone per ricavare una miccia lame
ma che cosa per salvare salviamo perché
se mi ritrovo il cane in faccia troppa
luce però ed è stato diverso tuttavia
tuttavia simile al 38 più controllo ma
su cosa e droga si chiama droga se tu
prendi qualcosa va in ecstasy c'è
l'uscita potrebbe essere soltanto
riflesso più semplicemente la mia
immaginazione ma sotto quella rocce
c'è qualcosa che attira la mia
attenzione lassù si infatti il no maisto
ciò che è bellissimo perché ti lasciano
un passo dall uscita però non puoi
uscire a queste rocce placè cos'è sta
roba è toglietevi un piccone tipo in
minecraft andiamo a trovare i diamanti
sembra antiche così da che innesca
capire cosa possa servire ma a me non
interessava anche quindi me ne vado st
porta qui non apro aperta permesso
ok c'è un buco piccolo non vorrei che
potessero passarci dei ragni qua io
spacco tutto il piccone può a posso
usarlo proprio come peggio del martello
ragazzi ok ragazzi le scatole non si
spaccano il rossetto è fame lo prende a
già mi dimentico sempre anzitutto
assegniamo il piccone a 4 poi farmi
prendere questo perfetto
o c'è qualcos'altro novità si qua la
recinzione elettrica creata di recente
meglio trovare il modo di andare avanti
come vado avanti
devo staccare la corrente dove si stacca
la corrente non è che riesco a tipo
no non penso però ci provo lo stesso ok
forse riesco a scavalcarla non penso
proprio però si sa mai a farsi sì
abbastanza alto
non lo so ci prova a ok no
così invece vuole valigia i ragazzi e
quasi si toglie fatemelo togliere dopo
che non serve a niente bravi ok ragazzi
explosivos chiusa la nazione ora come
cento la porta sembra molto fragile
vecchia so io come ci entro piccone
altro che martello di una sordi
picconate vedi che ti apri fa vigeva
sfonda porte gli serve dell'esplosivo
per qualcosa bombe madonna l'ici è pieno
di micce qua c'è una bomba che non
lancerei a prescindere ma che non si un
esplode faceva di dinamite wow è poi
stato fare qui che cosa facciamo
mariotti di polvere da sparo c'è un
forellino a parte superiore ma non
abbastanza da riuscire entrarci dentro
ma io c'ho il mio piccone se ti pago
tutto con questo cos'è polvere da sparo
asciutta ecco quello che mi serve e
prendi la però ha forse dove immergersi
il filo di cotone le istruzioni dicevano
per prima cosa i minimi di ram vicino mi
chiamo la miccia con la bac bac come si
chiamava max trina
ok adesso perfetto bene quella bella
miccia pronta all'uso
ok cosa mi serve a tnt ragazzi ok devo
tornare limone abbastanza di prima dove
c'è il cane morto e niente dove riuscito
a far saltare in aria qualcosa penso non
so dove l'ho lasciato la t a e coppa
tnt devo portarla probabilmente in quel
punto lì dove lo prima che ho trovato
poi madonna se pesa non agite ray troppo
però ragazzi
ecco questo qua sembra essere croato
forse anni fa ha rischiato l'intera
struttura potrebbe cadere mise la testa
da un momento all'altro tagliava
proseguire devo muovere l'ostruzione
forse c'è qualcosa che posso dare non so
qui torna sono rimasti degli espositi
allora miccia potevo salva dinamite
forza e ora l'accendo cometa facendo
accennino scarico wow
a ciò il gas per accendini però proviamo
ok perfetto proviamo vai via via via via
ieri a devo mettermi a riparo dai 3 2 1
sincronia allucinante ma non ci passò a
invece sì
cioè non ci passavo in quel biglietto di
prima dove la passato dal proficuo però
paci passo va bene anni avanti ok cosa
esso posto oggi che brutto perfetto non
mi l'odio
ok prosegue un po ma a quasi cioè non si
può proprio più tornano indietro che
allora siamo in un nuovo una nuova parte
di penombra che crolla tutto tra i
rumori questa zona sono sembrano alieni
alieni addirittura va bene ragazzi siamo
in questo nuovo punto non so che cosa ci
avrò davanti adesso probabilmente prima
era una cosa molto soft perché diciamo
dovevamo introdurci nel mondo riprendono
per adesso penso inizieranno le cose
difficile comunque difficili anche
spaventose finisco qui l'episodio
lasciate mi piace sulla pagina di
facebook
mettetevi piace video se mi è piaciuto
un commento è nt civili al prossimo
episodio super numero bella ragazza